in preparation for most sermons and in
particular this one I read a lot of
other people's thoughts on this text I
read other sermons I skimmed many
commentaries most of them had really
cute titles like quite a catch fishing
for Christ or by far the most popular
gone fishing well those get a little
cheesy for my taste but the one that
caught my attention was get out of here
hmm I don't like to judge a book by its
cover or a commentary by its title so I
read on and discovered that will
Willimon Methodist bishop had written
about this very gospel text a few years
ago in the Christian century he
commented on how the crowd was pushing
in on Jesus finally starting to maybe
understand what he was about attracted
to his sermons and his words but there
was Simon Simon witness to this crazy
unbelievable miracle and all Simon could
say is get away from me Lord or Willem
ins translation get out of here well get
out of here seems maybe the most
appropriate response because what do we
normally say when we hear the crazy
unbelievable too good to be true
miracles in the gospel get out of here
or what do we say when we hear Jesus
calling us out to the deep water get out
of here a sarcastic yet quite honest
response that we might find ourselves
saying quite often to the call of God
when I was a freshman in college my
chaplain pulled me aside the beginning
of the second semester and said have you
considered seminary well it had been a
long semester of fishing for the right
major not catching anything cleaning my
Nets after final exams wondering if all
of the work was just in vain but I was
also very content in my little small
boat with my communications major and my
tightly held dreams to be on the radio
someday
but I think God was speaking through
chaplain Brian that day when he nudged
me to consider exploring ministry well
have you thought about seminary he said
again my quick and baffled answer was uh
no translation get out of here and then
I had to also ask what seminary he
explained more and I said no no thank
you I'm very content in my small boat
with my communications major in my
tightly held dreams to be on the radio
but after each semester when I was
cleaning my Nets wondering if my work
was in vain he would find yet another
creative way to drop this hint subtly or
not so subtly so we were cleaning up
from an evening service he would say
well we are offering a course this
winter on exploring careers in ministry
in case you're interested my silence
became my way of saying get out of here
but simultaneously there was a snagging
curiosity growing and I hardly noticed
that I was gradually and repeatedly
being invited to go out to the deep
water this invitation came not only from
chaplain Brian but another voice that I
didn't understand a voice that promised
risk and also hope a voice that assured
me I wasn't going to do it alone but
this pull out to deep water was a much
slower process than for Simon & Company
it took years it's still going on I
don't think deep water is a place we can
ever get too comfortable there are too
many dangers out there too much unknown
but before we know it the tide has
pushed us back to the shore back to a
place of the safe secure shallow water
until God once again calls us out into
the deep and we have to decide yet again
how we will respond I'm not going to
bore you with the rest of the story of
how i got into ministry and i do want to
make it really clear that following the
call of Jesus does not necessarily mean
pursuing professional ministry in fact
another mentor in college turned to me
when he heard I was consider
this and said if you can do anything
else besides be a pastor you should do
it he was a little burned out himself
but he was also saying if God is
inviting you to the deep waters of some
other calling you better get in that
boat the boat made for you well when it
comes to the call of the disciples by
the lakeshore each of our four Gospels
tells a similar story but emphasizes
different details which I think are
really important in Matthew and Mark we
hear a very short story about the call
of Simon and Andrew brothers called to
be disciples Jesus gets right to the
point he walks up to them they are
fishing off the shore and he just says
follow me I'll make you fish for people
that's it they dropped their nets Jesus
continues down the shore to James and
John follow me I'll make you fish for
people they drop their nets that's it
the Gospel of John never as brief Jesus
stands on the shore and calls out to the
disciples out there in the fishing boat
hey have you caught any fish no we'll
just try throwing the nets in on the
other side of the boat and they were
full that's how it happens for John and
instead of Simon saying get out of here
or some version of that Simon actually
gets out of there himself he is so
stunned in the Gospel of John that he
jumps out of the boat but Luke chooses
to tell it another way Jesus gets into
the boat with Simon Jesus is back on the
beach in the other Gospels he's in the
boat in Luke and he tells Simon to row
out to the deep water the only time in
the four Gospels that it involves deep
water Simon explains they've been
fishing all night and haven't caught a
thing but agrees to give it a try and
they instantly catch a bunch of fish and
we know that Simon is so in all of the
presence of Jesus that he tells him get
out of here he feels unworthy to be in
the presence of God in the presence of
this miracle worker
Jesus but instead of Jesus just saying
follow me as we hear in Matthew and Mark
Jesus instead tell Simon do not be
afraid for now on you will be catching
people so the gift of having these four
slightly different versions in the
Gospels is that we have at least four
different lenses through which we can
hear and see this story in this year of
reading Luke's Gospel together in this
day of hearing Luke's miraculous fishing
story Luke's lens gives us some unique
ways to consider discipleship now
discipleship is one of those words we
throw around a lot here at this church
we sing about being called disciples of
Jesus we pray for strength to do it we
hear texts like today's about the
disciples of Jesus and yet discipleship
might not be one of those words you say
ever outside of these walls the twelve
disciples can be put on such a pedestal
in our minds that we forget just how
imperfect just how much like us they are
thus the task of discipleship can seem
so inflated and become one of those I'll
never get it right and may as well not
try kinds of things and yet we are
somehow drawn back here to this place to
this text to ask what it means for us
Luke story of the miraculous catch of
fish and the invitation to Simon to take
up a different kind of fishing might be
able to help us decode the loaded word
of discipleship now I hate tidy
three-point sermons but somehow I have
distilled this next section down into
three tidy points okay discipleship in
Luke number one Jesus asks his disciples
to go into the deep water but goes with
them that is key if discipleship means
getting into your metaphorical boat and
going into your metaphorical deep waters
then it is crucial to remember that for
Luke the deep water happens only when
Jesus gets in the boat with the
ciples where do you sense the presence
of God is it sometimes in those moments
when you experience risk or stretching
out of your comfort zone Jesus rarely
calls us to the convenient comfortable
complacent shallow waters but Jesus
doesn't call you to places where he
hasn't gone or isn't willing to go your
deep water is going to be different than
anyone elses deep water being here this
morning might feel like you're being
thrown in the deep end completely
unfamiliar this might feel terribly
risky and for other people this might
feel right at home regardless of what
the deep water is for you here's the
truth for Luke if Jesus calls you to the
deep water he's going with you second
Jesus asks his disciples to be honest
and then calms fears so discipleship is
being honest with Jesus simon doesn't
pretend to be all holy when he witnessed
the miracle of the fish instead he just
blurted out his honest fear-filled truth
acknowledging that he didn't feel worthy
to be in the presence of jesus also
Jesus senses Simon's fear in this
response simon says get out of here and
Jesus says don't be afraid Jesus can
take your honesty even if it seems rude
so if you sense that God might be
nudging you in some direction that you
just can't imagine going you may as well
be honest wrestle it out with God a bit
get out of here for Simon was his honest
and actually a pretty humble response to
nets miraculously so full of fish when
Jesus gets in the boat you won't be able
to hide very much but your honesty will
be matched with Christ's fear calming
comfort and presence and third
discipleship might invite you to leave
those Nets behind even as they are
bursting with fish
yeah this the disciples just leave their
nets and follow him and this might sound
even scarier than the deep water it's
not logical for the disciples to leave
they did not sit down and calculate how
much that was going to cost them in
losses logic was left way back there in
the shallow water a long time ago for
them though it wasn't logical to follow
Jesus out into the deep water after a
night of pointless fishing was it
logical for them to leave their nets
bursting with finance and security was
not logical but Jesus isn't logical
discipleship might not be logical it's
not a matter of just rearranging the
pieces of our lives to make room for God
somehow discipleship is being willing to
walk away from all of those pieces to
follow Christ you might not be called to
leave family or business or goals behind
but discipleship calls us to be willing
to do that or at least keep all of those
pieces in perspective discipleship is a
willingness to follow Jesus into the
unknown and I know that's terribly vague
and abstract especially for those of you
grasping for some clear picture of what
your future is going to hold we list
pros and cons we get everyone's expert
opinion about what we should do we try
to please family members or advisors but
all of this may not in the end help you
feel certain poet Wendell Berry writes
it may be that when we no longer know
what to do we have come to our real work
and that when we no longer know which
way to go we have come to our real
journey so all I'm saying is that there
may be a time when you feel drawn to do
something for reasons you cannot explain
in ways that don't make financial sense
or please other people and that
might be exactly what you are supposed
to do amen